[Music]
well hello there watching a press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages so time to see what is
making the headlines with kevin mcguire
associate editor of the daily mirror and
tim montgomery conservative commentator
both with us from now until just before
midnight welcome to both of you as ever
we turn our attention first of all to
the front pages inflation hits home that
is the front of the metro after the uk
consumer prices index hit nine percent
in april that is up from seven percent
in march and the highest for four
decades
prompting a warning from the chancellor
says the financial times that the next
few months are going to be tough for us
all
the guardian leads with a warning from a
senior police chief that the rising cost
of living will mean a surge in crime as
poverty increases
the daily mail though says that
ministers are considering what it calls
a triple tax cut to ease the crisis
but any hopes of a windfall tax on the
massive profits being made by energy
companies has been scuppered by
ministers that is according to the times
the daily mirror points out the
inequalities of the rising costs
comparing one pensioner's plight with
that of the chancellor himself
meanwhile according to the telegraph
western officials say that vladimir
putin is weaponizing global food
supplies by stealing grain and
destroying agricultural equipment as
part of his war in ukraine
and the sun brings us the news that win
or lose rebecca vardy and her husband
jamie are to leave the uk for america
after the result of the wagon the
christie libel trial
well reminded that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out those front
pages while you watch the program so
let's return to our guests kevin mcguire
and tim montgomery welcome to both of
you and uh tim the chancellor was
speaking to
business leaders today at the cbi it's
going to be tough uh and of course many
people at home watching this already
know that but the problem is the winter
higher inflation you know there is worse
to come that is the problem for for us
and the government
was definitely worse to come and people
feel it's difficult enough at the moment
anna but i think part of the warning in
the ft story and you read it in other of
tomorrow's papers is that there's not
just more inflation to come and people
are saying you know we've got this nine
percent inflation rate today i think for
people at the bottom of the pile people
for whom a large percentage of their
budget as food and energy the real
inflation rate is probably already 11 or
12
people expect it to go up by another
point or so
and then the worst thing after that is
most economists think that we'll head
out for a recession so we've probably
got at least a year perhaps 18 months of
really difficult times and while i think
the government has been slow to act i'm
a conservative i support this government
but i think it needs to move faster i
can slightly understand their reluctance
to sort of put out all the ammunition
that they may have now to help people
because they don't quite know how bad
it's going to get and of course the
government can announce certain things
now but that will never be quite enough
to deal with this crisis and by the
ultima by early next year people like
kevin people like the labour party will
be calling for them to do even more and
so i think that partly explains why
they're reluctant to do and make all
their announcements quite yet yes uh the
financial times talking about the worst
stagflation since the 1970s the good
news in the last two days of course has
been that employment figures are good
which was not always the case those
decades ago um so that keeps people at
least in work uh the daily mail though
if you move on to that um kevin the
tories triple tax cut boost there's this
huge debate underway about how this help
should be offered whether it should be
targeted whether it should be
generalized and what is the daily mail
saying what is the intel of all of these
newspapers
yeah
it's pretty it's pretty general but
nevertheless the daily mail which is now
on side with boris johnson and something
of a cheerleader under it's a current
edit a ted verity when unveiled at it
jordy craig seemed to want to pull him
down uh they say look the message is
getting through there's going to be help
for the lower paid three million that
looks like it'll be through universal
credit something on energy bills and
also easing the burden on
business to stave off in the daily mail
on its front page using the r word
recession because it's bad now with
inflation at nine percent uh
wages only go up four four point two
percent but it could get worse as we go
in if if we go into recession next year
or as the the financial times put it
puts its stagflation we have incredibly
low
growth but you have very high
in inflation and you watch prime
minister's questions today and the the
prime minister ruled out uh a windfall
tax on energy which
if it raised 2 billion it's probably 100
pounds per household on energy bills
it's not the sole answer but it would be
very very symbolic but according to the
times the prime minister is still
resisting that and they've been they've
been briefed clearly now that the
treasury and the chancellor rishi soon
would like it but boris johnson pm is
holding out and the the government you
can just sense in in westminster it
doesn't quite know what to do and has no
clear plan and i think it i think it
needs one pretty
pretty
quickly because
words words are great but people want
action and so you know it's
that's that's what that's what's
happening and it it seems certainly on
the on the windfall tax given margaret
thatcher brought we're not one on in
banks uh david cameron did on the north
sea it's a kind of odd hill for boris
johnson uh to die on should he be doing
that a resistance windfall tax when it's
just very politically popular and the
help would be
uh very very welcomed by those who are
facing prices when the boss of bp said
the windfall tax would essentially we're
making so much money now in um excess
bonanza profits that we could pay a
windfall tax and it won't cut investment
yes great picture of uh of uh what
looked like boyce johnson on the front
cover there but is actually kenneth
brenner in a a spitting image moment a
new sky drama about the pandemic so he's
at that photo you'll spot it on other
newspapers as we roll through but uh
moving moving back to the windfall
attacks just briefly as we saw the times
there certainly the the message from
premises questions was from sikhistan
you just don't get it and from boris
johnson and indeed from liz trust um
earlier on sky news today it was that
actually doing a tax like this deters
inward investment it means you lose
trust in business and in fact the
organization that represents um oil and
gas producers has highlighted today the
7.8 billion pounds in taxes the industry
is already expected to pay as a result
of the boom in oil and gas prices um in
a letter to the business secretary quasi
quartang and says that they work in
long-term investment cycles with
multiple and complex complex risks so
making the case written not to happen
where do you stand on this tim
look i'm not entirely surprised anna
that the oil and gas sector says don't
tax us anymore you know it sounds
slightly self-interested um i think it's
a little bit of a distraction though i
would happily support attacks on the
energy sector i think they're making
huge profits and i think they could make
a bit more of a contribution to the
economy at a time when people are really
hurting but i don't think the government
are doing enough to help the poorest
people in the country at the moment but
they are helping people by 22 billion
pounds already this tax even if it was
implemented will only give an extra 2
billion pounds to that so not even you
know 10
of what the help that's already being
funneled so the idea that it's you know
the big answer to the crisis we're
facing just isn't true where i hope the
government direct their help is through
universal credit the people hurting most
at the moment are the people at the
bottom of the pile don't know whether
kevin would agree with this but actually
universal credit had lots of problems at
the beginning it had lots of teething
problems but actually for example
torsten bell who used to work for ed
miliband now acknowledges that in the
digitalization of britain's benefit
system we probably have the most
sophisticated benefit system in europe
if we put money into it and so we can
direct money to the people who really
need it so let's have less talk of tax
cuts if money is short and let's really
help the people who really are having to
make the very tough choices between
putting food on the table or heating
their family homes yeah and certainly
people say our benefit system allows
help to be targeted but who knows if if
the people who are poorest are the only
people who need help that's the that's
the problem isn't it for the uh for the
chancellor um and in that cbi uh dinner
and address tonight the chancellor
suggesting i have had to be the crisis
chancellor he was talking about kovid
he's rolling straight into another one
isn't he and the guardian picks up on
that just quickly a reflection on the
you know the impact of all of this
yeah it's got it's got to be
acknowledged that the chancellor did
rather well in in covert with the fellow
scheme yeah there was there were
problems and laid decisions uh
on on extending help also the people who
were excluded but overall he he rose to
the challenge
now he's probably not doing that on the
cost of living crisis but the guardian
are just picking up another
social impact of this catastrophic uh
financial
confrontation for families that crime
will soar and andy cuckoo's the
inspector of constabulary
ex mersey side chief constable is saying
look police forces are going to have to
use their discretion on whether you
prosecute people who steal to eat which
presumably includes shoplifting because
poverty and the lack of opportunities
will create desperate people and tim was
mentioning people having to make choices
about eating and eating
i'm afraid you can you can condemn them
for stealing uh
as as much as we want but nevertheless
desperate people will resort to
desperate measures and you will get
people who would be usually law-abiding
will be driven to do things they would
not have done
before and what what is an economic
crisis is yes it's a political crisis
but it's also a huge social crisis
okay kevin uh tim stay there lots more
still to discuss
uh we will have uh more on the telegraph
tories under pressure
to name the rape case mp back with that
in just a moment
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview let us return to kev
mcguire associate editor of the daily
mirror and tim montgomery conservative
commentator welcome to both of you um so
kevin financial times picture there of
the turkish leader who is putting a
spanner in the works um of finland and
sweden joining nato with uh with a
fuller explanation here tell us more
yeah
he's put a spa in the works because
sweden hasn't uh
extracted 30 kurds so uh ankara who are
accused of being terrorists and it just
shows you there there is a front against
uh russia over the invasion of ukraine
an unprovoked very brutal invasion but
it's not united uh we see within the
european union hungary uh were resisting
uh energy curbs and now in nato you have
uh the leader of turkey who's very
authoritarian trying to block the two
new members uh quite how you get around
this i'm not sure presumably he wants
money or be bought off in some way
because uh to accept a new member in the
nato you need unanimity amongst the
existing members so i think it's a
little shaft of uh light for putin
best within nato for ukraine is of
course britain under boris johnson's
leadership isn't it kevin
he has he's actually done well on weapon
supplies he was slow on uh sanctions and
i think that refugee policy has been an
utter shambles and a bit of a shout out
44 000 ukrainians now in britain the
record number i think since the ugandan
uh immigration in the 1970s so it's slow
start i agree but actually it's turning
out to be quite a good policy i think
yeah he's been shamed
do you mind if i squeeze one more quick
story in while you you debate
that
and it's uh in the telegraph the metro
two uh which is um that tories are under
pressure to name uh the mp involved in
these rape allegations and also uh
michael fabricant as well tim who
tweeted and then deleted a tweet which
some suggested made a bit of a joke
about this situation
yeah uh michael fabricon who is a little
bit of a clown sometimes on twitter i
think went a bit too far today um of
course the suspicion has fallen on a lot
of conservative mps because the chief
whip said you know to the person accused
um at the moment stay away from
parliament so every tory mp wanted to be
in parliament to be seen today so that
they you know weren't thought to be
guilty but
um my own view in this until someone is
charged formally charged with an offense
i think it's wrong to name them i think
this is a very difficult area because of
course you want to also ensure that
you're protecting possible victims and
of course potentially by naming an mp
you might bring forward other people who
might have been a victim of this person
so i can understand the value of naming
someone but also i think until you've
actually the police have gone through a
presence which leads to a charge i think
anonymity is something that uh anyone
who's innocent until proven guilty
deserves yeah i i accept people are
innocent until proven guilty but at the
same time i think if you're arrested you
should be you should be named that this
mp is free to go into schools to see
constituents or unsupervised i think we
i think we in the public should know who
he is
tim knows i know you know
we've run out of time i do apologize for
finishing their